tout s'est passé tellement vite qu'on a
encore du mal à y croire le mur s'en va
alors vous l'avez certainement reconnu
mon collègue raymond saint-pierre il ya
de ça presque trente ans jour pour jour
parce que demain effectivement ça fait
30 ans que le mur de berlin s'est
effondré a été abattu ça aurait pris
plusieurs semaines mais quand même
raymond tout d'abord bonjour bonjour le
plaisir de vous accueillir ici
bah oui c'est l'impression d'être un peu
à la maison oui oui un peu beaucoup
alors quand vous voyez ces images et que
vous vous voyez vivre ces moments
uniques historique je pense qu'on peut
utiliser le mot historique qu'est ce qui
vient en vous voyant quand toujours des
frissons a vraiment parce que c'était
des moments tellement étonnant est
tellement ensuite mémorable parce que
c'était des jours et des jours de
festival de jouer à la grandeur de la
ville de berlin puis des genres de
l'excusé qui arrivent et qui découvre un
monde merveilleux pour eux avec bin
magasin avec plein de choses des
épiceries avait plein de choses à manger
alors que de l'autre côté c'était
vraiment vétuste et tout tomber un petit
peu en ruine c'est un système main qui
était un échec en fait ce système
communiste alors c'était ça moi c'était
des semaines de joie aussi l'idée
vraiment ils vous étiez basé à moscou a
permis à ce moment j'étais à paris on
allait souvent dans les pays du bloc de
l'est l'ancien bloc de l'est pas ce qui
se passer plein de choses ça bougeait
d'un peu partout et surtout et en
allemagne à partir de l'été là c'est
quand les gens des gens avaient le droit
d'un lest d'aller en vacances en hongrie
et là durant l'été ils ont commencé à
faire des pressions pour la hongrie
ouvre sa frontière qu'ils puissent
passer par l'autriche est ensuite allé à
berlin
le cercle a dépéri science qui l'épient
qu'on laisse finalement la main de
l'escroc nantes en est ce que vous
l'aviez vu venir et ce qu'on l'avait vu
non il y avait beaucoup de
bouleversements beaucoup de
manifestations
c'est pour ça qu'on était là aussi conçu
25 on est retourné beaucoup de
manifestations dans les grandes et les
piscines reste est aussi à berlin
c'est une ya entre des manifestations
tous les lundis où les jeux une
situation économique très difficile
oui puis les gens demandaient ils
demandent veut la chute du mur parce que
dans leur tête et dans la tête de tout
le monde
on ne peut pas pu dire ça ils
demandaient une vraie démocratie c'est
donc plusieurs partis politiques pas
juste un qui décide de tout tout le
temps et qui était vraiment comme une
dictature la manche dans un régime très
dur où ce avec une police très dur la
story oui exactement donc c'était ça que
les gens dénonçait puis voulais vraiment
que ça change
il avait vu qu'en pologne ça bougeait
aussi avec solidarnosc et tout ça il y
avait vraiment un vent de changement qui
souffle est à cette époque là mais les
gens ne savent pas c'est jamais cru mur
allait tomber
est ce que la présence de monsieur
riggen chance un an ou deux ans avant
plusieurs années
vous l'avez demandé est-ce que ça a pesé
ou sais ce que ça fait avancer les
choses
non je pense pas vraiment ça s'est passé
de l'intérieur c'était
à l'époque que sa vie avait pas internet
n'aimait pas les réseaux de télévision
ont amené présent partout dans toutes
les chambres dans tous les foyers les
gens mais pour accès à ces choses là
liste donc c'était vraiment plutôt des
choses intérieur les écoutais voice of
america is écoutait la bbc à la radio
même si c'était pas tolérée par le
régime
mais quand même ils savaient ce qui se
passe à l'étranger mais c'était vraiment
entre eux et c'était beaucoup dans les
églises par exemple où on a organisé les
mouvements de protestation vu j'étais
allé on était parvenus à entrer là où il
y avait des dissidents qui se réunissait
dans une église luthérienne à l'est de
berlin et les il jouait de la musique
justement du jazz des choses comme ça
mais aussi aux discuter de l'état de
situation du régime du besoin de
démocratie et de choses comme ça c'est
des milieux et c'est à partir de ces
églises lac ont organisé des
manifestations tous les lundis où on
criait nous sommes le peuple et c'est
devenu de petites manifestations jusqu'à
des dizaines des centaines de milliers
de personnes dont la chute du mur un peu
inattendu personne n'y croyait et enfin
chaque également pour les allemands de
l'est et pour tous ceux qui vivaient
dans le bloc communiste ça peut être
facile l'adhésion à la démocratie
l'arrivée de la démocratie dans leur vie
ça s'est pas fait du jour l'homme comme
dans tous les autres pays de ce bloc là
aussi je l'avais vu en roumanie aussi
une fois que le régime est tombé
le dissident qui on avait parlé en
roumanie sous le régime de ceausescu on
l'a vu après ces gens-là pensais
beaucoup de ces gens là pensait de la
démocratie si on fait ce qu'on veut
alors que la démocratie on a des
responsabilités des règles et on a le
droit de se prononcer on a droit de
l'obligation aussi de travailler de
faire des choses et tout ça et c'est un
peu quand on est dans un régime où on
n'a pas le droit de réfléchir on n'a pas
le droit où on est pris en charge de la
naissance jusqu'au cimetière rêve d'une
liberté totale à un moment donné oui
parce qu'on sait que ça existe ailleurs
et c'est ça donc ces gens là sont
débarqués à l'ouest évidemment un peu
comme dans un univers une autre planète
et ils étaient surpris puis des gens de
l'oise se demande qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec ces gens là qui ont évolué
pendant tant d'années dans un
j'aime aussi fermé qui ont des
industries des tullistes de tous tombés
en ruines du côté est qu'est ce qu'on va
faire avec eux puis encore aujourd'hui
c'est pas tout à fait finie je pense ça
c'est dans ma prochaine c'était ma
prochaine question d'ailleurs trente ans
plus tard avec du recul je vais
continuer à suivre la situation d'il
après vous y êtes probablement retourner
oui c'est un succès c'est un échec c'est
mitigé où on en est exactement sept
succès mais les gens sans doute l matin
même de la chute du mur les premiers
gens de l'ouest cela que j'ai parlé me
disait qu'il faut moment on va faire
pour absorber ces gens là pour leur
apprendre à vivre dans un système
tellement doux encore la question
aujourd'hui à la particulière vis à vis
a vraiment assez pour une discrimination
mais les gens ont encore de la
difficulté à l'est à entrer dans ce
système là où à être plus responsables
de moins dépendre de les passer sur qui
est encore un problème puis une
discrimination de la part de l'ouest on
a tendance à leur donner des mes
salaires plus bas et tout ça donc il ya
encore une distance sentiment de
citoyens de seconde zone
exactement c'est pas un nul mais un
obstacle mettons ya encore
psychologiquement c'est vraiment très
important
je m'en voudrais avant que vous quittiez
raymond de ne pas souligner le prix que
vous avez rapporté vraiment m'a fait
cette semaine
tout d'abord félicitations c'est un des
plus beaux prix des distinctions les
plus méritée ou les plus importantes au
québec pour un communicateur
vous l'avez reçu comment ce prix là on
voit d'ailleurs dans ce moment de
recevoir bâti l'assemblée lui à
l'assemblée au salon rouge de
l'assemblée nationale mais c'est un
hommage vraiment inattendu très très
important pour moi vraiment c'est la
reconnaissance le 2 2 perd aussi parce
qu'un jury quand même de gens du métier
le jury a choisi qui optaient pour que
mam accordé le prix à moi que de voir
vraiment aussi il n'y avait pas que moi
il ya des prix qui sont dans le domaine
de la recherche des scientifiques et/ou
penu du côté culturel avec 3,3 par
exemple des zones à risque de se
retrouver tout ce monde là ensemble a
dans le même club et ensemble on a passé
beaucoup de temps ensemble à discuter
c'était une aventure fascinante de
côtoyer des talents aussi brillant
qui sont chez nous là cette fantastique
m'écouter nous à radio canada on aura
bénéficié pendant encore plus de 40 ans
de vos talents raymond je remercie on
vous félicite encore pour ce prix là ah
merci merci encore de nous être venu
nous parler de ce que vous avez vécu il
ya 30 ans des moments historiques
exceptionnels très présent dans notre
vie ne les avais raconté de manière
extraordinaire merci beaucoup merci